what's happening you bad
[__] uncle joey here you guys
are saying what how you been you but i
forgot about you [__]
never i'm in jersey here
uh what's the word i'm looking for
decompressing
from uh l.a my family's having a great
time they're at the pool
we went and looked at the house today
tremendous
everything is working out but hey talk
is cheap
i was gonna hit you up for a little
peyton day maybe i want to do a little
friday afternoon happy hour here
you know sometimes they come at you at
night sometimes they come at you in the
morning
today i feel like coming here in a
friday afternoon to let you know
i didn't forget about you [__]
you know what i'm saying
and for you people who are wondering
joey what are you gonna do about reefer
in jersey don't worry about it
i already got a box shipped i got
another one on the way and i got another
one on the way you know what i'm saying
that's how we do it
both episodes have been released this
week i hope you enjoyed them
uh patreon you know i love you
[__] i'm messaging you
i'm trying to do my best to keep up with
the [__] uh with you savages
let you know i still got your back i
still love you i'm still thinking about
you
we close in the house the 31st
we're moving on the first hopefully we
can get some up for you
but if not i'll keep communicating like
like this with you [__] just to
let you know
it's on my mind you know what i'm saying
what the [__]
you know i know you watched the
democratic convention last night
whatever
joe biden and i don't i don't give a
[__] about none of that [__]
i give a [__] about you people that's it
man how we're gonna go on to the next
[__] level of this
new jersey doing good it looks good
people are eating
i went to a diner today i got a nice
open turkey sandwich
you know me dog no points turkey
i'm still trying to keep it together i'm
going to go swimming in a little while
burn some calories keep up you know
that's it
i'm just trying to decompress from what
i left in los angeles i could not
believe
what my eyes saw in that period of time
and you know me though i've been in a
bunch of weird [__] situations
but that situation was moving quicker
than i had ever seen before in my
[__] life
and i wasn't gonna listen you know me
dog i'm too old
i'm too old i was walking around
strapped i don't need that in my life
man
you know when i got up when i got to put
a gun in the [__] car
i don't like it i don't like it at all i
left that [__] gun right there i
couldn't
i didn't want no problems with nobody i
was seeing things
in studio city north hollywood that you
wouldn't see in like a [__] bad
neighborhood
but you know what we're done we're out
of there
i'm happy i got my wife i got my kid
and i got you [__] to deal with
so
that's it it's a friday afternoon we
made it another week without [__]
drama
the plane ride was smooth everything
went smooth man uh
like i said this is more of a family
move i wanted my daughter to go to
school
the numbers are low and [__] new
jersey believe it or not they're lower
than there
and [__] los angeles new york's a
mess i have not been there yet
but from what i'm hearing you know what
are you gonna do
all we can worry about is about
ourselves and the future and what we're
gonna do
and how we can keep this [__] going
we gotta start laughing again and
giggling again and [__] breathing
again and seeing our friends again
but it's all gonna take time and i'm
with you i know you guys are [__] you
know
but i'm with you
i would love to tell you i'm up there
jumping up and down with people and
[__] partying the studio
that's not the case at all that's not
the case at all you know i got my issues
you got yours you know hopefully i get
my back up on [__] stage
and just break through this [__]
that's the plan i think once i get on
stage
i think everything will be [__] when
i see you [__] laughing
face-to-face again
i think i'll be better i think that's
the answer that's been the answer i
wanted to avoid it but
i think i'm going to hit a [__] stage
any two things are going to happen
either i have a heart attack
or [__] destroy the audience that's
my options so if somebody
came to you with those options joey you
either got to rip them apart
or you're going to get a heart attack on
stage from being scared
[__] it i'd rather go with plan b i'll
rip you [__] apart so
i even started writing a few [__]
little pay pates
about what i've been going through the
last [__] six or five months whatever
long this is
i've aged we've all aged look at
yourself in the mirror
look at your friends on media social
media when they take a picture we've all
aged
this has aged us this is how hard this
has been
so if you're having a hard time right
now i don't want you to beat yourself
up this is what it is smile
relax take a breather go for a walk
enjoy the people that are in your life
don't turn on them
enjoy them it'll make your life a lot
easier
trust me it's uncle joe and all about
this [__]
i'm smoking some tremendous reefer from
urban trees
i just called my boys over in cali at
u.s cryotherapy i miss
them i want to say [__] goodbye them
but i was too busy you know i miss parts
of l.a i'm not going to tell you that
cali sucked or whatever that that's not
me that's not my [__] style
i had a phenomenal time that way i love
you [__] i miss you
it was just time to move on to the next
level of life
and here we are smoking dope doing the
same thing we're doing
only on this side of the [__] country
who's better than us
you guys got me so excited i'm gonna go
inside after i finish here and i'm gonna
pop an edible
out of respect for my patreon family
because that's how i [__] roll you
know what i'm saying
that's it and that's that i just want to
check in with you
let you know that i love you i didn't
forget about you
i appreciate your patreon i appreciate
the messages
you know i message you [__] i
get to welcome some of you
you know i got a goal on how many people
are welcome you know
i'm working it though don't think i
forgot about you uncle joey's
always close by
any questions all right then
and we're good we got together
we got to see each other we get to smoke
a little
roots
can we get to know everybody's gonna be
all right and that's it and that's that
you want me to taste them i don't know
what the [__] okay i don't even watch
the [__] news
the news is the same every day you're
gonna die that's it
joe biden this guy you know a [__]
fire i know california is burning
i don't mean so the only thing i'm
burning is this [__] joint with yukon
suckers
have a great weekend patreon i love you
guys
with all my heart thank you very much
for your support
you'll see me this weekend somewhere i'm
going to pop up on your [__] little
screen here
and that's it and that's that
it's friday afternoon what are we doing
it's time for an edible i love you
[__]